il ya six mois à eux qu'elle aimait
salaf beach et maintenant il demande
spéciale l'audience se trouve sur le jeu
le plus dur du monde une version 2.0
aura comme ses marques à l étrange parce
que oui je sais lire oui donc c'est
parti new game alors welcome ce brassard
dégâts mais il faut maintenant on va où
plus de tirer mais je sais comment jouer
mais j'étais champion du monde à
l'époque
alors c'est parti allez on espère en
espérant que cette fois aux petites
nouveautés fin il me semble les vestons
sur elle-même ce qui est tout à fait
incroyable
oh mais [ __ ] le niveau le plus cliqué
du jeu java mourir pas bonjour up tac et
voilà j'espère que c'est devenu un peu
trop attention
olala holl holl alors au 7e maîtrise au
à cette maîtrise mac tiger où es-tu où
es tu j'étais pas demandé de me montrer
que tu sait boxer et oui gmail tiger
young mike tyson
qu'est-ce qui a bon tiens veut se battre
non pas toi pas toi voilà va falloir se
cacher comme un vieux ce texte ça a
amené make you came here we want picture
of my axe là on est déjà neuf morts
actuellement alors ça fait moins le
malin petite boule bleue misérable oh
[ __ ] les mecs c'est bon les gens ça a
passé un jour ou l'autre c'est obligé
[ __ ] mais au niveau 3 quoi j'ai sué
pas là tu m'as pas vu je suis un simple
petit carré rouge qui cherche son chemin
au plus tard vers le retour à maintenant
ça se fait pas ça ok autant d'un truc
non non non non quoi tant de haine dans
ce monde de brutes un fichier par to
make him principales objections
j'aimerais tellement avoir le coup de
main la bim bam bam en plus ça c'est
super normalement il ya une zone verte
en fait dans les nouveaux pour ceux qui
se souviennent et quand on touche cette
zone verte sa sauvegarde là à sa
sauvegarde là on est mais apparemment la
zone verte bas elle est inexistante dans
ce niveau là où à mes mecs
ah [ __ ] l'enculé birds c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible ça m'a
touché le cheveu même si un cube n'a
battu veut on s'en fout il ya bien un
moment où ça va passer quand tu tires ou
tu pointes
je vais puente [ __ ] jaua
habia maria ces techniques en fait pour
basso et pourquoi pourquoi ce ce petit
car ils pouvaient pas s'entendre avec
avec ses roncquois je comprends pas
qu'est ce que c'est que ce sexisme ce
sexisme géométriques
c'est n'importe quoi bon allez on arrête
de dire de la merde vous n'avez pas idée
de comment ce niveau de merde [ __ ]
mais comment est-ce que je vais devoir
appeler mon homme aimait croquer les
militants bowles n'a pas pu mettre ce
n'est pas une musique meilleur en plus
je sais que je disais sur chaque jeu
mais sur chaque jeu je fais la musique
elle te torturer les oreilles tort vie 2
2 3 2 up de prendre des trucs dans la
tête
mes voisins me croire je me fais
séquestrée dans une cave 1 mais bon
c'est à peu près l'équivalent quand on
joue à je sais à peu près même chose à
ma part tirs directs dans 3 2 1
[Musique]
oh oh oh oh c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon
qui passe
[Musique]
arrête arrête de mettre des droites je
sais que tu sais boxer est ce que vous
voyez la même chose que moi est ce que
ces niveaux est faisable dont je ne
pense pas à vous allez on va t'en allez
on y va en mode
ok voilà en mode je me fais tuer à
[ __ ] j'avais jamais trouvé le truc là
ah mais mais mais cela mais quand
ok c'est bon j'ai compris je vous prie
j'ai pas gauvrit non je déteste les
boules
ouais je déteste les boules est ce qu'on
va pouvoir aller de l'autre côté
maintenant faire le retour non je ne
pense pas allez on y va
non
aulas aurait pas aimé où est-ce qu'ils
sont pris aux j'aurais pas aimé un jeu
rennais c'est qu'un joueur que tu gagnes
ou pas ils n'en ont rien à [ __ ] spa
forêt à l'aller les gens n'y croient
chroniqueront en croise les doigts on
croise les doigts tous ensemble croisons
les doigts faut aller en bas donc là
juste aller en bas de façon de manière
totalement irrationnel voilà comme ça et
là là ça va se compliquer au le bordel
bon je vais tenter un truc un tasseau
faut bien se lancer un jour oui oh non
[ __ ] faut tout refaire
oui j'ai déjà fait ou n'a réussi pièce
iss est sa [ __ ] ça fait plaisir enfin
là je me sens mieux
ah voilà bah on va se mettre en jaune en
jaune parce que le jaune what the fuck
parce que le jaune c'est super l'heure
des amateurs est terminée voilà donc là
apparemment on passe aux choses
sérieuses aussi aux choses
incompréhensibles
oh là là non mais vous avez vu ça oh là
là je suis bien là je me sens bien ah ah
oui j'avais pas vu lui lui cet esprit
universel
voilà sam fisher la norme en la je suis
bien là on est bien là là c'est comme un
sauna pour un humain c'est juste un
carré pour un carré voilà je comprends
rien je croyais âge le tour derrière et
maintenant pour tous et dans la zone
vers ho [ __ ]
ok c'est bon ya un timing est à brax à
you ready made by then jack lawrence et
ben tanfous y aller au hall à la hausse
ça mérite le cul mais tellement fort ce
qui vient de se passer au lala
mon dieu mon dieu ramenez-moi d'updike
en émoi du talc watts
olala m'essayer un conte banques devront
là mais ça fait moi dans ce jeu je
demande qu'une chose pour mon cube
si j'étais le tube la seule chose que je
voudrais c'était c'est tout je veux
vivre les et voilà et pas mourir à cause
d'un et non voilà pas comme ça non plus
et puis ça a été un jour vos attendent à
ce qu un jeu moderne anciens
la marge brute a marre des relations
sexuelles avec le bol qu'on fasse tous
la paix et que je me fasse pas gang bang
plus tard je suis déjà vous annoncer que
que j'ai importé a bien fait ton ça
allait la tenture est terminée la fête
est déjà fait je dansais bien là je vous
pouvez mettre cette mesure alors on en
boîte
la sicav n'apportez pas et je te dire